I want to make a couple of those
particularly on one and two and three
kind of follows along with it like have
another question one how many of you
chose to your first line was to multiply
both sides by a number who tries to do
that heads up straight from you can
hands them so what do you did something
differently it quitting maybe people to
put on the work what did you do instead
of multiplying everything by a jumbo any
takers
because they were quite a few you didn't
do that yeah okay so you could cross
multiply right did you get the run in
time okay any other suggestions
yeah okay so over here on the left you
could just well you're not adding you're
subtracting you can put these fractions
together first
leave that two alone and then you can do
some cross coefficient they're all fine
my point is you can't do a life here
right it really doesn't matter which way
you turn that we've seen already
sometimes different methods to give you
more fractions or less fractions or more
negatives or less [ __ ] have a look at
the person next to you I encourage you
to do that see if they solved in a
different way they're trying to sign
like which way do you like better do you
like the way you did that well maybe
your data actually has a more efficient
happy wait happy now that's all what to
say about number one number two let's
just look at it briefly
now um very kindly we actually have some
working on the board and I want you to
help me go through this dissection
really really useful for you to do and
you should do this with each other have
a look at the working and I wonder if
you can articulate for me what has
happened at each step we actually have
some indication but can we articulate
for example from here to here before
this stuff happens what does this line
represent what action is taking place to
those from here then
expanding very good we have words for
this though right so we multiply both
terms here by four it's correctly
expanded context then up to that right
he added two times why did he do that
why do you add it to both sides
yeah good way it's an equation so we're
doing the same in both science and in
particular what he wants to get rid of
is that negative twenty redcine-x 20
that's why there's a 20 there it's going
over to the other side I'm adding 12 or
20 and then he divides it off it goes so
this this looks really good to me okay I
want to suggest maybe another thing you
could do when you look at this that will
be a different first step we're really
good at expanding so it's kind of like
have you heard that phrase when you've
got a hammer everything looks like a
nail
you see if you haven't read that phrase
what it means is what do you have a tool
in your hand you think of everything you
can do with that too regardless of
whether it's appropriate to do like why
should I you to have up on like opening
my mail no well you could if like I'm
trying to spread butter on across my
piece of toast hey that's okay heads
like a black surface alright that kinda
makes easily really now I would suggest
that actually even though expanding
going on gets us to the right answer we
didn't really need to do that if you
have a look carefully of this first line
can someone give me alternative and
there aren't that many but what I could
do instead of expanding yeah yeah its
division during right set up you're
kidding right are there fractions I
should get rid of them by multiplying
yes get rid fractions by multiplying
here I have multiplying well the way you
get rid of that is by dividing it like
you think about what's opposite so here
if I divide by 4 and divide by 4 do you
see what's gonna happen
kids will cancel talk about 4 of course
is 3 so you get X minus 5 equals 3
you're still gonna land on the right on
top the same on top but I would argue we
got there quicker and
places for errors to creep in okay so
you see I am I give a big thumbs up to
that but always think the whole point is
I've given you a whole suite of
techniques to use try to use the most
efficient one okay